Here's an interesting stitch pattern
that I'm calling Connect the Dots.
It's worked with short rows,
and it isn't hard to knit, but it takes
a bit of planning and concentration.
Let's figure this out
by knitting a single repeat.
Looking at the diagram,
notice that the dot is worked over
nine stitches outlined in red.
It'll be knit using partial knitting,
and these five rows in the diagram
represent a single row
in the knitted piece.
The gray boxes in the diagram are
needles that are held out of work.
The curved symbols remind us to wrap and
prevent holes when changing directions.
To practice knitting one repeat
of the dots, start by casting
on 19 stitches with the main color.
Knit 6 to 8 rows and end
with the carriage on the right.
Remove the main color
from the carriage and set it aside.
Set your carriage to hold so that any
needles in the D or E
position will not knit.
Opposite the carriage,
pull five needles to hold.
Thread the carriage with the contrasting
color and knit across 14 stitches.
Be sure the edge stitches knit
completely and wrap that first needle.
Opposite the carriage, put five
needles plus two more in hold.
Knit to the right and confirm
all the stitches knit correctly.
Don't forget to wrap.
Opposite the carriage again, put two more
needles in hold, knit left, and wrap.
Opposite the carriage one last time,
put two more needles in hold,
knit right, and wrap.
This completes the partial
knitting for the dot. Now
put five needles plus two in work
and knit left.
Break the contrasting color yarn
and remove it from the carriage.
Now put all needles in hold position.
With the carriage remaining in hold,
free pass to the right and pick
up the main color yarn.
Now cancel the hold setting.
Thread the carriage with the main
yarn and knit eight rows.
You can bind off or just drop
the knitting from the machine.
For an all-over design,
we'll repeat this sequence across the row
and then knit a few main color rows
and repeat the dots again,
alternating the position of the dots.
Have fun knitting your connect
the dots stitch pattern.